is about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I plays Morgan uncensored tonight Eco
yobs calls more Mayhem at the tennis
this time on the day the Prime Minister
hosts a summit of stopping them wrecking
our summer of sports Dale Vince Bank
rolls Jost up oil and he's back for
round two
children identifying as cats horses and
dinosaurs refusing to talk to teachers
except with animal noises how do we fix
this utter nonsense in our schools well
Britain restricted his head teacher
Catherine bubble Singh has some thoughts
and joins me in the studio
plus a 90-minute marathon a 15 meter
long jump swim as fast on the speed
boats yes a drug in Hearts Olympics has
been the subject of pump speculation for
years but could it now become a reality
the entrepreneur behind the so-called
dope Olympics joins me to debate his
controversial plans
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored well good
evening London welcome to piersburg and
uncension now before I begin tonight's
show I want to issue a trigger warning
the following production contains adults
with opinions some of which you may
dislike as well as discussions of world
events some of which are bad
you've been warned and if you think that
disclaimer was unnecessary we'll take it
up with the makers of a new production
of a sound of music that heartwarming
romantic musical set against a bucolic
Alpine backdrop
Chichester Festival theater saw fit to
warn ticket buyers to brace themselves
for references to Nazi Germany and war
quotes themes they may find distressing
really
anybody in the world ever found the
sound of music distressing it's a very
latest in a very long line of books
movies artworks stage shows history
lessons and university courses to be
slapped with a trigger warning they're
supposed to alert people of sensitive
disposition do harmful content which may
trigger their hidden traumas there is
actually zero evidence that they
actually do that but at this point they
are very triggering to me yes the
triggers are triggering to me the
trigger warnings are triggering to me
all of it is triggering to me and here's
why the University of York added a
trigger warning to its archeology course
because students May occasionally see
human remains or bones
I'm triggered by that isn't that the
bloody point of an archeology course
the Globe Theater added a trigger
warning to Romeo and Juliet for violent
language sexual references misogyny and
suicide
oh yes It Was Written 400 years ago and
by the way you just ruined the ending
trendy forensic investigators the
University of Exeter are now warned
they'll see pictures of crime scenes
well duh
here's a little warning for you again if
you see a bag of peanuts it might
contain nuts
the Royal Academy of Art slapped a
trigger warning on a Francis Bacon
exhibition over adult content
if they expecting many children
this weekend emerge that Virginia wool's
novel to the lighthouse has been given a
trigger warning over concerns about past
attitudes
now readers of the book may have
expected past attitudes already since
the book was actually written in the
past
enough of this madness perhaps the
reason why everyone's so anxious is that
we're telling them they should be every
time they open a book or go to the
theater or watch a movie or do anything
patronizing it's infantilizing it's
nonsensical and it doesn't work
Flinders University in Australia
actually studied all of the other
studies about trigger warnings and they
found they don't prevent anybody from
being triggered in fact they found
anyone with genuine trauma was more
likely to be upset by the trigger
warning because it made them think of
the one thing they didn't want to think
about
so it's official trigger warnings need a
trigger warning
one more time
well we'll debate that later but first
two yes you've guessed it the just stop
oil morons take 56. prime minister
Richie sunac held a summit with event
organizers and National sporting bodies
today to discuss how to stop these
cretins from Wrecking our summer of
sport he told the Sun newspaper that
Johnny bestowed the cricketer had some
bright ideas for fixing this blight
here's a reminder of what bestow did
thank you
very so just waving to the dressing room
maybe it's his gear
thank you
we also had to do it and he threw him
over the sidelines like a piece of trash
which is what they are frankly will play
inevitably on chord 18 at Wimbledon was
briefly suspended twice today when just
stop oil protesters scattered orange
confetti and jigsaw puzzle pieces over
the court
please
[Applause]
and another disruption
although the reaction of the crowd did
you detect Universal support for this
movement
cheers of yes you go you go just up Oil
we're right behind you or did you hear
what I heard which is loud Relentless
booing jeering and abusive shouts from a
public sick and tired of this
it's another PR owned goal from a
protest group who seems determined to
become the most hated in modern history
and elsewhere an annoying protest
anti-monic is demonstrated as targeted
King Charles in Edinburgh today
here they are with their trademark
yellow t-shirts and backyards as the
king arrived just in Giles Cathedral
[Applause]
[Music]
how many people do you think they won
over today or anyone in the crowd going
you know what I've actually gone off the
Royals I think I'll joined the movement
I doubt it um well I'm joined Now by a
friend of the show where is Posner from
the anti-monarchy group Republic and
also by the green Tycoon and Justin
boiled backer Dale Vince so Dale uh
Vince uh we're welcome to both of you
but let me start with you Trevor Nielsen
who is a big supporter of uh groups like
just op oil came out in the Sunday Times
last week and said it's become
disruption for the sake of disruption
working people trying to get their job
get to their jobs uh dropping kids off
at school or just enjoying themselves
there's now a case where pink hair
tattooed and Pierce protesters stand in
front of the cars so their kid is late
for example it's just performative it's
not accomplishing anything I actually
believe it's become counterproductive
and I just feel like that has to be said
by someone involved in the beginnings of
what it's become this is going to
require an immensely difficult
navigation of the middle and the
activity are ostracizing the exact
people they need to engage they're
creating an excuse for people to stay on
the sidelines blocking Bridges he said
is a lot easier than Building Bridges
and that's what we need to do if we're
going to succeed I think he's right
isn't he I mean I just don't see any
upside now to what these just stop all
protesters are doing they are
deliberately wrecking ordinary peoples
in many cases hard-earned enjoyment
watching sport that they love and for
what
my turn
I think it is so look
um I think your language is
exaggerating right they're wrecked sport
they aren't wrecking people's lives the
climate crisis is Wrecking people's
lives it has killed four million people
already and it does make 20 million
people every year homeless right I call
that disruption quick it was about three
minutes today there was more disruption
at Wimbledon from the rain than there
was from the protest so I think you're
making much of it I think they are doing
a good job because they continue to put
this issue on the news agenda but
everybody hates them
listen to the crowd to the crowd here
okay that's not everybody is it pissed
around at Wimbledon is not a single
person applauding that's the cheering at
Wimbledon right that whole crowd at
Wilmington like the whole crowd at Lords
I was there for that uh like all the
crowds all these events that they're
wrecking or trying to rake with their
attention seeking the truth is the
British public are absolutely sick and
tired of this it's just not working
Trevor Nielsen's right it's backfiring
it's seen as performative seen as
attention seeking and it is destroying
Bill uh Bridges rather than building
them
the strategy is it working
well I disagree with you and with Trevor
I think performative art has a powerful
role in our society actually in shaping
how we think about things and what we
think and I think that these very brave
people are putting themselves In Harm's
Way and and creating a constant media
attention for the climate issue which we
have to have because it's doing such
great harm and it's driven by fossil
fuels and our government are intent on
drilling for more oil and gas to make
the problem worse what they're going to
do excuse me is harm people actual harm
to people their lives and their
livelihoods by drilling the North Sea
for more oil and gas they're going
against the scientific consensus and the
political consensus globally to do this
foolish thing claiming it will lower
energy bills which is a lie because they
know that they can't do that because
fossil fuels are priced by global
markets we allow them so so again like I
said to you last time I have a lot of
sympathy with a lot of the arguments I
think we should do a lot more than we're
doing as a globe although my real issue
is with countries like China and India
who are by far the worst polluters in
the world it's not actually the UK and I
don't see any of these heroic protesters
getting on a plane to Beijing or to
Moscow or to Mumbai there's a moral
cowardice about this they're targeting a
country which actually has been doing
more than almost any other to be
Progressive in this area but aside from
that if you're going to have a movement
you've got to bring people with you I
don't know anybody literally anyone who
is watching these scenes time and again
at all these sporting events and
thinking that's going to make me join
this movement it actively puts people
off
okay how about some facts on China
because it comes up all of the time what
about China the per capita carbon
emissions of the people in China yeah
are tiny right way smaller than they are
in Britain and just last week it was
announced that China has built more
solar panels than the rest of the world
put together right which includes
Britain and they're at 50 green
electricity on their grid now and that's
where a country of over a billion people
what percentage what percentage of
pollution what percentage of the global
pollution comes from China
bear in mind is 1.1 billion people
making most of the world's stuff
including the stuff absolutely
tell me now you tell me you're the
expert
I'm telling you per capita as an
individual per capita it's a percentage
of global what's important percentage of
global pollution there are eight billion
no
you don't want to tell me three billion
people on this planet I'm telling you I
don't know you should tell me right I'm
telling you I don't care per capitaire
globally
they're built more solar power than the
rest of the world put together peers and
they're at 50 green on their electricity
grid I say those are amazing
achievements when you say what about
China yeah I say they they produce more
than a quarter of the world's pollution
and I don't see anyone from Greta
Thornburg to you guys getting out there
to Beijing and shouting at them or
wrecking their sporting events and we
all know why let's bring in rizz is
chuckling away because you find all this
terribly amusing uh rizzu supported just
up oil uh no one at Wimbledon today
supports just up oil they just sent you
a bunch of idiots I know you weren't
there today you were shouting at the
Royals up in Scotland why do you support
this kind of protest that we're seeing
at all these sporting events
oh I'm not sure I've completely condoned
that and to be clear I'm not speaking on
behalf of Republic today I speak on
behalf of no more Royals but absolutely
we are protesting in Scotland and peers
you're gonna like you've just been going
on at these guys they're just a while
about why are you disrupting Ordinary
People and why don't you target the
right thing and we've been doing that uh
shouting at the king why do you support
that method of protesting why do you
come out and condemn Justin Boyle like
Trevor Nielsen who was funding some of
this stuff before I suddenly realized
the pennies dropped it doesn't work
uh I'd like to talk about
coronation because it's but uh to
respond to that question uh we're in a
climate crisis is horrifying I'm
terrified for my future and just the
foil are one of the only groups of
people at the moment who are doing
anything about that but as I say I'd
like to focus on the issue well I'm sure
you would I'd like to focus on what's
just happened because it's indicative of
of a summer of protest by people who
think they can convert people to their
cause even if people are inclined to do
so we're now at a point where you can
tell from the audience reactions at
these events they literally want to
garop them and what worries me is it's
going to lead it is going to lead to bad
situations if this carries on because
people are going to just going to take
the law into their own hands
uh sorry that's stupid sorry you don't
keep swearing do you want to talk about
the process you don't have to keep we
wanted to talk about the protest or do
you want to say uh that protest
shouldn't happen and we should all suck
it up and deal with it because that's
easy for you right like you've been
dealt with pretty good hand I believe in
peaceful protests uh but I actually care
I believe in peaceful protest do you
want to talk about the peaceful process
I believe in peaceful protests I don't
believe in Wrecking ordinary people's
lives is they going to work is they
going to hospital as a on summer cases
going to funerals I don't think that
when they play for sporting events that
they maybe save money for all year long
that's fine
they shouldn't have ruined by a bunches
let's talk about it there was a republic
up at one end who were a massive crowd
far bigger than any of the monarchists I
mean the streets are pretty much empty
uh I haven't had a chance yet to look at
any of the coverage but I think you'll
see that because uh that is pretty much
nothing going on on the Monica's end and
the Republic demo is enormous
uh and then there's no more Royals who
did a banner drop uh chanting can I
swear I just did uh the king feed the
hungry because that's what we want to
talk about right uh
they've done this you know what race for
a bright young woman who's getting a
very good expensive education you do
behave like a complete foul-mouthed
idiot you don't need yourself any favors
why do you think coming on a show like
this and just repeatedly using the f
word why do you think that makes you
look any better yeah I did apologize for
that three times that in advance but
that was what we said three times yeah
uh F the king yeah I'm happy to censor
it uh F the king
um feed the hungry that's what we were
chancing uh because that's what we
should be talking about today the first
coronation was ridiculous it was a slap
in the phrase of the British people you
asked for a question it's this do you
really think do you really think the
best way to persuade people of your
argument is to come on a show like this
laugh man technically of people who are
doing ruminous things to people's
enjoyment and then just keep swearing
all the time do you think that really
helps you do you think people watch this
and go she's really persuaded me that
girl while she was so eloquent she was
effective they don't they just think
it's again the formative attention
seeking you want to get your little
YouTube moment and by the way you'll
probably get one and good for you but no
one's going to come around to your cause
that's it I can promise fair enough
um I actually don't want that YouTube
movement moment uh I don't want your
fans calling me assorted slurs on
Twitter
um and to be fair right I did say at
multiple points can we talk about the
issue can we talk about this outrageous
by the way I don't think we've even
mentioned I mean everywhere there's been
a second coronation and no one showed up
um you know I can only apologize for
swearing but uh yeah I think the
Laughing was more to do with your
ridiculous coverage of it well as always
always a pleasure to have you on thank
you very much coming back to you Douglas
let's let's finish on something on a
more positive note you've just appointed
at your football club which you own
Hannah dingley as caretaker manager
she's the first female manager of a
professional men's team in English
football quite a groundbreaking moment
yeah
it is I just want to say rizz is right
the first coronation costs 200 million
quid right for hard push Britain
struggling with the cost of living
crisis just want to say that Hannah
dingley football yeah we pushed another
boundary right how can it be that in
2023 no women has led a men's first team
in the top four flights of English
football how can it be but there it is
until tonight when we play our first
preseason friendly game against melchem
I'm looking forward to it why is she
only caretaker manager if you believe in
her that much
you're such a twister of words
have I have I misquoted it's quite
uh yeah sorry you said if I believe in
her so much right is she caretaker
manager has she been appointed full-time
or caretakers
half of what you said was true the other
half was made up yes she's caretaker
manager and if you know football you
know that's quite normal you've just
sacked the previous manager after six
months so how long will you give her
she's
she's I thought we were talking about
something positive but you can turn
anything into the fragrances I'm a big
football fan you've got a lot of good
headlines in publicity for appointing
the first female manager but actually
she's only caretaker you know and people
will be curious you've seen the last you
sat in Alaska after six months if you
were to sack her after a few weeks or
months how's that going to look
who knows but look what happened was
unexpected for us and Hannah's been with
us four years leading the academy when
we made that appointment that was the
first ever we didn't know that at the
time we found out afterwards this one we
were aware of but Hannah was the best
qualified person at the club to take
this role this interim role so she got
the job we didn't want this media storm
really didn't want it at all but here it
is you didn't think by pointing the
first female caretaker manager of a
professional men's team you would get
any attention
she's the best candidate for the job at
the club this is what happens you look
at within the club you find your best
coach and you say take the team in an
interim period while we do a proper
recruitment process that's all that's
happening here and look you guys in the
media you've made much of it and I think
it's not all bad actually I mean you
have a particular negative way of coming
about it but for the actual whole
country to understand that this is a
momentous first and it really shouldn't
be not in 2023 then I don't think it's
such a bad thing well it is unless you
sack her after a few weeks
that's why do you keep coming back to
that
of appointments she's only a caretaker
so if you believed him that much you've
got all the publicity but actually yeah
it works and I suspect what's going to
happen is football you're going to
probably go and find a bloke to replace
it and then you're gonna have to deal
with that I
I thought you understood football piss I
do I'm an awesome thing
I was going to ask you that but that's
cool I thought they had a good season
last season actually I was rooting for
them to win the title uh we choked but
there we are that's football we've made
some good signings Jackson rice will
take us to the title next season uh Dale
I hope she succeeds she's there for a
long time I hope I'm not interviewing
you again in a few weeks time when
you've replaced it with a man because
that would really be awful uh but great
to talk to you well I think
I think at least we weren't talking
almonds and avocados so I'm happy we can
come back to that next time
because I'll talk to you later and says
the next tonight children identifying as
cats dinosaurs even a moon what is going
on in our schools and what's the answer
I'll talk to Britain strictest head
teacher some would say best head teacher
Catherine bubble sing next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we literally have everything from Kiss
condoms to kiss caskets we'll get you
coming and we'll get you going there is
a kiss toilet seat oh yeah I sit on my
face
but I tell you what kind of a big deal
when I was singing that I was chewing
gum and I said Mr Simmons please take
out your golf because I'm a wise guy I
said eBay how much Pierce Morgan let me
guess five thousand two hundred and
forty seven thousand dollars well for a
busy gone Gene Simmons
[Music]
well that Gene Simmons interview is one
to watch it'll be tomorrow night for the
hour one-on-one uncensored with one of
the most charismatic rock stars probably
ever but welcome back to Pittsburgh
Catherine bubble Singh is the self-style
strictest head teacher and Brett with a
stellar reputation for teaching children
basic manners and respect and hard work
ethic I can't think of a better person
Frankie to speak to when I read that
children in schools across Britain are
identifying as cats horses dinosaurs and
in one case a moon a reminder of the
leaked audio recording that brought the
bizarre Scandal to light featuring a
teacher reprimanding children for
refusing to accept a class-based
decision to identify as a cat
if they want to identify some power or
something then they're like generally
yeah crazy
you're questioning that there are again
a question I was just saying about the
gender I haven't said anything about
them but what did you get this idea from
there's only two genders gender is not
linked to do with them
gender is about how you identify that
you identify with the gender that of the
sexual organs
which is really despicable
well Catherine what did you make of that
when you heard that tape and read the
story behind it
yeah well um actually for some weeks
before the before that I had been
talking about cats in schools
um because I know of teachers in schools
where that's happening it's called
furries right this is a real thing
exactly and and in some places you know
they're able to wear ears and Tails and
things and um the thing is I don't blame
the schools because don't you no because
in fact in some places the parents are
coming in and telling the schools this
is how you must treat my child so why
don't the schools just say no you would
wouldn't you well I bet there are no
kids at your school dressing up as cats
identifying as cats oh that's true no no
there are you wouldn't allow it would
you well no but I mean I
I mean I'd have a conversation with the
parents and that's the thing this isn't
just a school problem this is a societal
problem and it's something that we need
to talk about and think well what what
is acceptable and what isn't
um and the problem is there's no
guidance for schools as well so head
teachers and ordinary teachers in the
classroom what are they meant to do I I
do feel sorry for them really because
they're getting in the neck and I and I
get that it's it's difficult but just
well I don't think it is that difficult
if a kid identifies as a horse in the
classroom you're not obliged to tolerate
it yeah and again I don't think you
would no but you know I do have
secondary school children you know their
primary they're young if you have
children that are finding it difficult
to fit in and then they they decide to
behave in a particularly it's a slightly
strange way how much do you support
what's you know what stage do you feel
you're enabling them or you're you're
helping them you know it's difficult
it's not it's not a straight cut it's
just saying well this is just you know
silly I mean it is this this also plays
into Limitless self-identity which must
be causing all sorts of problems at all
sorts of schools yes
um how do you deal with that and what's
your view of that yeah well it is
difficult I mean and we need guidance
it's it's very hard because it isn't
just the schools it's also the parents
and the difficulty that any head teacher
has is trying to balance what they feel
is right for the children at their
school and what they're offering and
then also trying to do what's right by
the parents and what the parents but
there are now girls schools marketing
themselves as girls schools selling fees
as girls schools yes for their girls to
go to a girls school who now Outlaw the
use of the word girl because there may
be some people identifying as non-binary
you may be offended I find that absurd
yes but then the rest of society
possibly doesn't and that's the
difference well I think most of society
does actually but would they say it out
loud you know no that's the thing but
that's that's where we've got to I would
because I think it's nuts yeah and also
I think it's very hypocritical of a
stool to Market itself as a girls school
yeah and then suppress the use of the
word girl so I think there's a real
hypocrisy there yeah but there's also a
bit of a moral cowardice I really do yes
I mean schools in when I was young
schools took a moral lead yes I don't
remember teachers Marching In and having
everything changed yeah acquiesce to
what their idea of of teaching would be
yes but that and that's the case with
all kinds of things this is not just
from God to this issue but with regard
to everything schools used to take a
moral stance on things and used to lead
the way for a society are you due to a
degree yes we do but I think we're quite
and you've become very polarizing the
result for reasons that completely
baffle me yes I mean you run a school
which is run on discipline and hard work
ethics and politeness and respect yes
these used to be things that we thought
made our country great I know I know and
what's going on why are you suddenly a
villain I don't know it's a very good
question you would think that this would
be what all of us want but it Society
has changed that's the thing so then
when you're saying it's the fault of
schools but you look at this I stand up
for Traditional Values and I'm hated for
it so do you really expect all head
teachers to do that we're asking too
much of them but the real problem with
that whole issue is when schools aren't
communicating with parents where schools
are taking children down certain roads
and are not letting parents know the
parents being too weak or too strong I
mean are they having too much power in
our schools or are they being too weak
with their kids empowering them to have
supposedly too much power yeah well both
frankly I think teachers and parents we
as adults have abdicated Authority and
responsibility and children depend on us
to push back and to show them the way to
to guide them and lead them and
unfortunately I'd say over the last 40
to 50 years we've lost the whole concept
of adult Authority in parents and
teachers want to be friends with the
kids as opposed to Being the adult in
authority you've had a big spat this
week with Jess Phillips from the labor
party and you've actually written to the
Gear style of the leader in a in a
nutshell what was it about well there
was no spat she just attacked four times
to 630 000 followers for no reason
um I don't know just Phillip she doesn't
know me uh and she sent out these tweets
for her followers uh saying that I
believed in domestic violence this is
because when Tina Turner died you
tweeted a picture of her with Ike Turner
well it was not a functioning GIF and
for some reason it ended up on that
picture and I said good times and
obviously anyone normal would look at
that and think well it was a mistake but
she chose the opportunity to to lash out
at me four times a million views a whole
load of people attacking me she's an MP
Minister for safeguarding or a shadow
Minister
um she called into question the
safeguarding policies at my school she
called into the question my ability to
do my job why I mean I don't have
anything to do with Justin well is it
because you gave a speech to the
National conservatism conference in
other words they they view you now as
being political well on the other side
you say that in every political
conference party political conference
there will be head teachers and teachers
who speak at the labor conference at the
conservative conference but what doesn't
happen is a blackhead teacher who goes
and speaks to the National conservative
conference which had nothing to do with
the conservative party but the fact is
there is an unconscious bias on the left
where they they sort of believe no and
not everybody on the left but too many
think that black people should not lean
conservative and the fact is that's true
I do lean conservative generally
speaking but I believe in unconscious
bias that's quite a leftist idea so I'm
a bit you know I have ideas from both
sides and the problem with this
particular type of unconscious bias is
that because it belongs to the left the
left rejected the right don't like to
recognize racist unconscious bias so
neither side is recognizing that this is
an issue I think it's something that
pretty Patel sowella barberman Kimmy
badenart I think they suffer from it too
I think I suffer from it regularly where
people say how dare you go and speak at
that conference and I think well why
shouldn't I speak at that company well
some of the things you said I was
cheering you know and I don't identify
as right wing but you said the
conference uh that the audience should
act as if they felt their children's
schools did not reflect the small C
conservative values what I'm asking you
said how much do you love your country
yeah how much do you love the values
that you claim to defend you love them
enough to tweet under your own name you
love them enough to change your child's
skill to one that's less woke ignore the
impact on your social status if you love
them enough to do more than simply chat
to your friends who already agree with
you at dinner parties For Heaven's Sake
man you said stand up and be counted as
Russell Crowe says in the film Gladiator
a clip you regularly paid to your staff
Hold the Line Stay With Me what we do in
life echoes in eternity that's right I
wanted to cheer that yeah not because I
think you're conservative yeah but
because actually these used to be values
yes which most British people held and I
just bet a lot more still do than people
think well and what I was trying to say
to them is if you think these things
then get up and say it for goodness sake
and you know after I spoke to them a
woman stopped me on her bike on the
street and she said I'm going to speak
out more I'm going to say what I think
and I thought great that's all we need
to do because too many people are quiet
about it I totally agree you know there
is a silent majority they're getting a
little noisier yeah but they're all
countiled by canceled culture exactly
because the woke left have been
basically terrorizing people that's
right and they've come for you hard and
I'm very glad to see that you've
continued to put your head over the
parapet have you heard back from Kirsten
no but it hasn't been that long I'm
hoping fingers crossed well not Jim I'm
sure he'll respond uh great to see you
thank you very much thank you very much
well it says the next a major ice cream
company gets political of course it does
urging the United States to hand back
indigenous land but attacking the
founding fathers
the Mount Rushmore attacking that on
July the 4th my stellar pack will join
me to unravel that debate and others
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Associated to Kevin McGuire I want to
play a clip this is from Australian
morning television today with the
Australian prime minister decided to
give have a little pop at me take a look
at this
let's talk about the ashes Rishi surnak
who looks like he could blow over in a
stiff breeze uh he's fired up about the
ashes is it time to revoke the Visas of
English Elites like Pierce Morgan just
get rid of it just don't let him come in
that's it
well I I think that would be a very
harsh measure uh Carl what what it might
be better to do is to allow people like
Pierce Morgan to come in and to come on
your show and remind him of Australia's
massive ashes Victory both the men's and
the women's team are nailing it over
there in the UK yeah prime minister just
for the record You've Won nothing yet
the ashes are alive and that headingley
tomorrow is going to be the Coliseum the
Yorkshire version a new lot are going
down so I will be on that breakfast show
in three or four weeks talking about a
thrilling comeback by England to win the
ashes 3-2 and the women are going to win
too so I would just put a cork in it
copper
um right
let's move to our pack
um so there's a I love this story
transport for London bosses abandoned
advert for a new player in the West End
because it features a Victoria sponge
cake and the ad apparently promotes the
consumption of high fat salt and sugar
sugar foods and didn't comply with the
organization's advertising policy so
they've now had to rip it down this is
for a Broadway show Tony and Tina's
wedding which has this cake in it
uh I don't know where we start with this
Kevin
when do we say you couldn't have a big
cake yeah there's a promo I know look
there's an obesity Problem in London as
there is in the UK and much of the world
certainly the developed world so the ban
is on Advertising that's pushers
unhealthy Foods I think this is core
into the production look I think it's
Daft I think they need to tweak the ban
so you can't say buy kicks oh please
I did my monologue today on these
trigger warnings right how it's been
established that trigger warnings
actually trigger people who the warnings
are supposed to protect because it
reminds them of what they're supposed to
be not thinking about right I mean we
are literally going nuts here I do
curious whether actually there's a link
between between Banning ads of ads of
unhealthy foods and whether people stop
consuming them right because I don't
think anybody looks to the production
for a a Broadway show which has a poster
of two characters on a sponge cake and
they think a Moscow yeah but but makers
are very sugary and fatty unhealthy
Foods would not spend a fortune on
Advertising if they didn't think it was
show I mean if there's if anything will
make me want to say oh I agree I agree
all right I'm actually buying a cake let
me bring in Caddy who's a welcome uh
visited to Piers Morgan our Center so
you've done this book The Power uh Power
code what is that the power code the
power oh the power it was you know oh it
runs right okay more joy let's say your
maximum impair for women it's the
problem with all these things are too
many women not in charge or are too many
women in charge of these bad decisions
no I mean we've stalled at the top of
women we've got only 10 of CEOs are
women 30 out of the world 300 countries
have women leaders women improve the
bottom lines of the companies they work
for so we were trying to look at why are
women not progressing why have they not
got to the top and one things we found
is that actually there was a study out
of Harvard showing that women don't
really want Power they look at Power and
they think the cost of getting it too
high power itself seems unappealing I've
met some power crazed women yeah of
course there of course there are going
to be people women are in power Who
Loved willpower the old way what we were
looking at is why aren't they
progressing and what could you do about
power itself to change it to get more
women I mean if the world was in a
wonderful State we wouldn't have thought
you need to change things but are you of
the belief are you of the belief that
that if the world was run by women were
world leaders we would have less turmoil
and War we haven't got any evidence on
because there haven't been enough women
lead so I'm all of this is you know data
and research I'm not going to tell you
that if women were running
but we do know that women when they run
companies for example there's more women
in senior positions that companies
improve the bottom line of those
companies they make more profits which
most companies would think is a good
thing so we want more women at the top
you spent uh 20 years in the states
reporting a lot for the BBC obviously um
every week now it seems to be a story of
a corporate a kind of woke corporate
campaign spectacularly backfiring it
started with Gillette after the metoo
campaign when they suddenly went all
Every Man's a Harvey Weinstein until
they prove otherwise 9 billion came off
the bottom line they had to reverse and
go back to Alpha Male advertising we saw
the Budweiser thing with Dylan Mulvaney
the transgender influencer Modelo now
the biggest selling beer in America
because of that right yeah um and we've
seen it with Target who did a lot of
stuff during pride month and got
attacked by it by consumer base and now
we've seen Ben and Jerry's the ice cream
you know champions in America always
doing pretty much of those stuff but
they chose July the 4th to launch this
can pain to basically Guilt Trip America
about indigenous rights which is a
perfectly legitimate thing but on July
4th they actually targeted Mount
Rushmore obviously the four faces they
said making them out to be a bunch of
brazen thieves when in fact the four of
the great president of the United States
I suspect this will backfire I suspect
there'll be a run of campaign against
Ben and Jerry's where is always going to
go I don't know I don't know if the Ben
and Jerry's case will backfire because
Ben and Jerry's have long been known and
associated with liberal causes so I
think that people expected of Ben and
Jerry's to some extent I think CEOs in
America I'm sure you've spoken from
peers are increasingly being put in a
position perhaps because of failure of
politicians to get things done where
they're having to take positions on
social issues that they don't want to
whether it's immigration gun control
um you've seen companies take positions
on that too I think it's incredibly
awkward for the CEOs I don't think they
can because they're partly because
they're client-based but also mostly
because they're employee-based because
employ younger employees in particular
are pushing CEOs to take these this
reminds me Esther of the conversation I
just had with Catherine Burleson which
is parents and students now driving yeah
the power we're seeing this now with
young employees I quite agree with you
these companies driving them to take
very woke positions Disney had just had
this huge Buster around DeSantis in
Florida I don't think they should be
doing any of this stuff well it's a case
of the inmates are running the Asylum
because actually back in the day you
know as arrogant as I think my
generation is we the previous
generations you knew that you could you
have to keep your mouth shut when
someone were 20 plus years of experience
of speaking at the very least but now we
have these young people that think they
know best they they have access to the
internet they know more than everyone
else and I think that's the bigger
problem I don't think it has to do with
the consumer base actually for these
companies because you tend to divide
that I think I like it when young people
you know the new generations challenge
the older Generations I actually think
that's
get the decisions right now in Ben and
Jerry I think their marketing is
fantastic they're getting talked about
again the people who will go and spend
their dollars or pounds wherever you are
Euros on Ben and Jerry's probably like
all this we know we know but what if
what if they go down the Budweiser route
stir up division
on July the 4th the day of unity I mean
look as a brick
I don't you know obviously celebrate
July the 4th I think we dropped the ball
under old Mad King George but that's
another matter but the idea of an
American company that's been very
successful in America launching this
attack on the very idea of July the 4th
on July the 1st and then it's an
invented myth idea of July the 4th it's
not the true story
and they just celebrate independence
from the Brits yeah
Before I Let You Go who's going to win
the election 2024 America
I think Joe Biden probably wins but if
something happens to him or to the
economy a month before the election I
think Donald Trump's the nominee well
what a choice Yeah country of 330
million how can it be this
and we're gonna have a rerun yes and I
was exhausted at the end of the last
time I was also just thinking about it
uh a power coat it's terrific and Claire
Shipman uh really I'm going to really
enjoy uh showing this to people let's
see what they think have a good to see
you thank you very much thank you next
been the subject of Pub debates and
Twitter speculation for years Olympics
where all the athletes were allowed to
take as many performance announcing
drugs as they want the founder of the
controversial enhanced games or the
doping Olympics that they're calling it
is here next
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and sensor what
might be possible to support a
performance enhancing drugs were all
allowed 90-minute Marathon a 15 meter
long jump some of the stars on the speed
bows well we might soon find out the
inaugural enhanced games or the doping
Olympics as it's been dubbed aims to
rival professional Athletics with a
Twist you can basically take whatever
you like I'm joined by the president of
these enhanced games Aaron de Souza and
five-star Olympian Mark Foster all right
Aaron uh send it to me what Earth should
we want or have a doping Olympics where
everyone just dopes themselves up
because science is real Pierce medicine
is real technology is here so is
cheating it's not cheating at all we're
creating a level open playing field
shooting is happening at the Olympic
Games because they have a highly
constrained environment with an
artificial rule set and in the enhanced
games we want to do everything out in
the open to create a much safer fairer
you did be serious about this absolutely
do you think you can genuinely put on an
event where everyone's doped up
absolutely so like like the cycling when
last Armstrong was doing but they're all
on drugs and it's much safer Pierce when
it's done out in the open but whether
it's like illegally
legally prescribed clinically supervised
performance enhancement regimes all
right Mark this might sound completely
nuts
but is is the existing system being so
discredited with so many cheats is there
some method to miss Madness no well I
was wondering if it was a reason why I
came in to see whether it was a serious
thing and whether these things are going
to happen and how far it's gone uh my
head tells me that it's completely
unsafe and I think people abuse it and
people die from taking drugs on a daily
basis anyway I don't just I mean
performance enhancing drugs and I just
think where does it go we've seemed to
have safeguards in place yes some people
slip through the net there is Wilder the
world anti-doping Association do have
things in place and there still are
people out there that do cheat if they
choose to but it's very small minority I
just think looking at this from the
outside it's just got death all over it
has I mean what you're going to do if
people start dying because they're all
trying to out dope each other they're
all taking whatever they want it's a
completely insane idea isn't it you're a
lawyer I mean yes I am a lawyer but
aren't you just going to be on the
receiving end of massive amounts of
losses well in fact there are quite a
number of inner National sporting
competitions that do not have drug
testing the X Games for example which is
probably the most prevalent Challenger
at the Olympic Games does not have drug
testing the NFL the NBA Major League
Baseball have uh drug testing regimes
that are not compliant with water the
Olympic Games is
well it's it's much much lighter uh
because the power all the limits off and
you're saying anyone can take anything
so if people want to win and I think
there's money at the end of it or a big
prize or whatever it may be they're
going to take a lot of stuff and that is
going to be very dangerous well we must
believe that athletes who are adults
with free and informed consent should be
able to make choices about their own
bodies my body my choice your body your
choice enhancements are present in our
society I say you have a coffee cup
right there caffeine is the most used
enhancement probably in the world right
and should the government or should some
paternalistic Sports organization be
telling you peers how much caffeine you
should be able to drink all right Mom I
again this I mean I think the idea of
this is insane
but it's a coherent argument if you want
to go to that insane
way my issue I think my concern like
yours is it just seems incredibly
dangerous I mean I I spent I represented
Britain for 23 years at senior 11 and
went to five Olympics and and I abided
by the rules I think people always twist
the rules I I'll always be amazed by how
far somebody could go if they took
something but the bottom line is I don't
think that's got any place in sport at
the moment I I just don't see people
watch it uh probably possibly I don't
know a lot about the X Games I think the
thing is there's wants to be competition
towards ioc because ioc's the Monopoly
of the Olympics and there's another
sporting body that's one thing but I I
don't see this the Olympic games has had
a monopoly on power they've run the
international sporting world for 120 and
you want a piece of that action I want
to show the world that there's a better
way not to waste hundreds of billions of
dollars of taxpayer money every four
years by building dozens of stadiums
throwing them away and waste and
Corruption upon corruption there's a
better way to do Sports and most
importantly to people like Mark a way to
pay the athletes and your argument is if
they're all doping none of them are
cheats that's right absolutely it's fair
but how do you stop how do you stop and
die I do something done clinical
supervision right so how how do people
not die from taking pharmaceutical
medications when you go to your doctor
you talk to your doctor openly and
honestly about what you're intending to
do the conditions that you're suffering
from does that mean they're still sort
of compete on the rules then because
they're all as you say they can't
overdose themselves you'll say there's
still rules and regulations where they
go and get their drugs from yeah
absolutely we would never encourage
anyone to order steroids online from a
sketchy Pharmacy in Mexico and inject
themselves that's really that's what
athletes when are you hoping to get this
event on December of 2024 is when we
anticipate are any top athlete's going
to do it they told you I am pleased to
report that we have over 400 athletes
who have registered on our website we
have athletes like Christina Smith Brett
Fraser Roland Schumann Olympians all
around who are on our athletes Advisory
Board
um and it's time to shake up the system
it's time to have a conversation okay
how fast can the doping Olympics coming
to a TV screen near you I'll believe it
when I see it but thank you for coming
in mark thank you for coming here that's
it for me we're already up to Keep It
Uncensored and in my estimation if
you're an athlete undoed good night
thank you
[Music]
good evening I'm fears Morgan I'm
censored in New York City tonight on
Piers Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan
Tonight a special edition of Piers
Morgan uncensored Martina navratulations
do you believe you can win this war so
are you gonna run again I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy yes I
feel betrayed they're trying to force
you out yes not only the coach but the
other two or three guys there around
well these people protesting just don't
get it many of them don't isn't that
slightly patronizing
I would call it
call it psychiatric assessment I'd be
there for three weeks did you keep quiet
I'm trying to read the book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
XY where are they where's their children
why isn't someone on the roof with the
castle it's from that much cushier gel
that galane Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him you're
shaking your head the British people are
up in arms Boris Johnson is out as
British prime minister the conservative
party can certainly win
yes
this is the Royal team question is did
he say yes I have taken drugs and they
bent the rules to give them the Visa or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it